y
[Música]
el gobierno de finlandia aprobó
formalmente solicitar el ingreso del
país a la otan la decisión debe ser
ratificada por el parlamento y podría
poner fin a casi ocho décadas de
neutralidad militar de esta nación algo
que el kremlin ha advertido sería un
error la primera ministra de suecia
también informó que su pais solicitaría
su adhesión a la alianza atlántica
y en medio de un profundo descontento
social y con pocas expectativas de
cambio líbano voto para renovar el
parlamento se trata de los primeros
comicios legislativos desde el gran
estallido de 2019 las primeras
informaciones hablan de una
participación en torno al 41 por ciento
el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden condenó el ataque armado que dejó
al menos 10 muertos en la localidad de
buffalo en nueva york' el mandatario
hizo un llamado a enfrentar el odio de
autoridades revelaron que el agresor
había recibido previamente tratamiento
de salud mental
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 el 6 rodrigo sedano y es un
gusto acompañarlos comenzamos este
informativo en finlandia donde el
gobierno anunció su decisión formal de
buscar su adhesión a la otan el anuncio
lo dieron el presidente del país a uli
ministro y la primera ministra sana
marín en una conferencia de prensa
conjunta ahora seguirá un proceso
parlamentario para formalizar la
solicitud con esta medida helsinki
abandona la política de neutralidad que
mantuvo durante años desde el fin de la
segunda guerra mundial finlandia
comparte más de 1300 kilómetros de
frontera con rusia quien advirtió de
consecuencias en caso de adhesión al
bloque atlántico más en la siguiente
historia
hace meses era solo una perspectiva
lejana hoy finlandia rompió con décadas
de no alineamiento militar cuando
anunció oficialmente que quiere unirse a
la otan un giro provocado por la
invasión rusa y ucrania
el presidente de la república y el
comité de política exterior del gobierno
han acordado conjuntamente que finlandia
solicitará el ingreso en la otan pero es
contra cotto anna aunque nato ya sea
previa consulta al parlamento de
hospitales y está bien ex han pasado
muchas cosas de la última vez que nos
reunimos aquí el 24 de febrero si este
es un día histórico se abre una nueva
era
un camino que suecia también quiere
seguir el jefe de la otan james total
berg dijo que los dos países serán
recibidos con los brazos abiertos
finlandeses son los socios más cercanos
de la otan su ingreso en la otan
aumentaría nuestra seguridad compartida
y demostraría que la puerta de la otan
está abierta
nate del sur con el apoyo a la adhesión
a la otan ha aumentado drásticamente en
ambos países
todos los miembros de la alianza quieren
poner fin a esta guerra lo antes posible
pero estamos igualmente decididos a
mantener nuestra asistencia de seguridad
de ucrania señor continuar con nuestras
acciones controles de exportación y
presión diplomática sobre rusia mientras
rusia sigue con su guerra el ingreso de
finlandia y suecia en lo tan es
exactamente el tipo de movimiento que
moscú quería evitar cuando comenzó su
ofensiva
advirtió de las graves consecuencias
como la amenaza de desplegar armas
nucleares en kaliningrado este
territorio ruso está ubicado entre
polonia y lituania miembros de la otan
europea
entretanto más dale la anderson la
primera ministra de la vecina suecia
informó también en rueda de prensa que
su país pedirá la adhesión a la otan y
que irá al parlamento el lunes para
asegurar un amplio apoyo a la solicitud
de ingreso
anderson aseguró que suecia necesita las
garantías de seguridad formal que vienen
asociadas a la alianza atlántica y
reconoció que durante el proceso el país
se puede ver en una situación vulnerable
pese a todo apostilló que este cambio de
guión en la política sueca no supone
dejar de apostar por el desarme nuclear
a nivel mundial
nosotros los socialdemócratas creemos
que lo mejor para la seguridad de suecia
y del pueblo sueco es que nos unamos al
otan esto es una decisión que fue tomada
después de cuidadosas deliberaciones
para nosotros los socialdemócratas es
claro que la no alineación militar ha
servido bien a suecia pero nuestra
conclusión es que no nos servirán
también en un futuro
vamos ahora hasta territorio ucraniano
la ofensiva de las tropas rusas continua
centrada en la región del donbass el
ejército de ucrania reconoció avances de
los soldados rusos al tiempo informó que
emprendió una contraofensiva en las
cercanías de la estratégica ciudad de
icio en la región de jarquín al otro
lado del país en el bid cerca de la
frontera con polonia un ataque ruso con
misiles destruyó infraestructura militar
y la seguridad alimentaria de millones
de personas está en riesgo como producto
de la invasión de rusia ucrania y de las
intensas sequías de diversos países del
planeta la oficina de las naciones
unidas para la agricultura la
alimentación advirtió que podría
avecinarse hambre desnutrición protestas
flujos migratorios y tensiones
geopolíticas en diversos países
se aproxima a una crisis alimentaria
mundial el conflicto entre rusia y
ucrania quienes representan casi un
tercio del trigo y la cebada del planeta
ha disparado los precios de los
alimentos sumándose a una crisis
energética que impacta a los sistemas de
distribución sandwich caption pero tal
vez en polonia y bulgaria que gastan una
mayor parte de sus ingresos en alimentos
estarán mucho más afectados por los
precios más caros el sur de europa
áfrica egipto y los países árabes
también son grandes importadores de
cereales es posible que se enfrenten a
faltas de suministro y precios más altos
estos países realmente sufrirán el
mercado de alimentos ya venía en crisis
entre otras cosas por la pandemia de
kobe 19 además enfrenta la intensa
sequía que afecta a países como francia
eeuu canadá y la india este último tomó
la determinación de prohibir sus
exportaciones de trigo por sentir su
propia seguridad alimentaria amenazada
los ministros de agricultura del g7
rechazaron la decisión
la prohibición afecta a países como
bangladesh y nepal que necesitan el
trigo con urgencia los jefes de estado y
de gobierno del g7 deberán tomar una
decisión concreta sobre este tema y
hacemos un llamado a la india para que
asuma sus responsabilidades como
miembros del g20 pero la india no es la
única nación que está respondiendo a la
crisis con proteccionismo una veintena
de países ha colocado medidas
restrictivas de exportaciones
ante esta situación el temor es que
millones de personas y ciudades podrían
ver a corto plazo hambre desnutrición
protestas flujos migratorios y tensiones
geopolíticas los representantes del
banco mundial el fondo monetario
internacional la organización mundial de
comercio y el programa mundial de
alimentos han llamado a realizar
acciones coordinadas de suministro de
alimentos de emergencia soporte
financiero y comercio abierto para
apoyar a las naciones más vulnerables
el sábado por la noche el grupo kaluz
orchestra representante de ucrania se
convirtió en el ganador del concurso de
eurovisión 2022 en medio de la guerra
con rusia tanto el grupo ganador como el
presidente de volodymyr selenski
aprovecharon la ocasión para recordar al
mundo que ucrania todavía necesita ayuda
internacional alva santana no es amplia
[Aplausos]
como un soplo de aire fresco para los
ciudadanos ucranianos sumidos en guerra
con rusia así se celebró la victoria del
grupo la lucha orchestra en el concurso
de eurovisión de este año en la ciudad
italiana de turín cada pequeña victoria
es importante para cada ucraniano para
nuestra ucrania para cada uno de
nosotros los ucranianos lograron ganar
con una canción que fusiona el rap con
la música folklórica
[Música]
dedicada a la madre del vocalista del
grupo y es que el asedio que está
sufriendo ucrania la convirtió en la
clara favorita de esta edición con un
récord de votación del público a su
favor y felicitaciones por parte de la
comunidad internacional y otros
organismos como la otan
winnie división context me gustaría
felicitar a ucrania por haber ganado el
concurso de eurovisión y no lo hago a la
ligera porque ayer vimos el inmenso
apoyo del público en toda europa y
australia
tradicionalmente los ganadores acogen el
certamen el año siguiente
algo que ucrania espera poder hacer en
2023 con la esperanza de haber dejado
atrás el conflicto con rusia
nuestro valor impresiona el mundo
nuestra música conquista europa el año
que viene ucrania acogerá el concurso de
eurovisión haremos todo lo posible para
que un día los participantes e invitados
de eurovisión sean recibidos en una
mariupol libre pacífica y reconstruida
no obstante en medio de las
celebraciones tanto el grupo musical
ganador como los políticos ucranianos
aprovecharon para mandar un mensaje
ucrania todavía necesita toda la ayuda
que se le pueda brindar
[Aplausos]
j
inicio el conteo de los votos tras el
cierre de las urnas en el líbano el país
celebró los primeros comicios
legislativos desde el estallido social
de 2019 y mientras continúa ha sumido en
la peor crisis económica de su historia
desde beirut y tell bonet corresponsal
de france 24 nos cuenta los detalles de
una jornada que ha contado con una gran
abstención los cálculos indican una
participación cercana al 41%
la jornada electoral ha transcurrido con
bastante normalidad
a pesar de una serie de altercados que
han habido en algunos colegios
electorales repartidos por el país pero
que no han sido nada remarcables la
verdad es que el desaliento en general
ha hecho que no haya habido una
participación masiva que ha alcanzado
prácticamente un poco más del 40% el
líbano lleva asumido desde hace años en
la peor crisis económica de su historia
moderna y los libaneses no ven una
salida cercana a esta crisis el sistema
político libanés es un sistema
confesional por lo que cada secta tiene
una cuota de poder y es por eso que el
resultado final no lo marcan los
resultados electorales de los candidatos
que han ganado hoy de los partidos
políticos sino que se verá cómo queda
dividido el hemiciclo con las nuevas
alianzas con los dos bloques con más
poder en el parlamento estos son las
fuerzas del 8 de marzo y del 14 de marzo
el bloque del 8 de marzo está liderado
por hezbollah y su aliado
a mal y también el partido cristiano del
movimiento patriótico libre del
presidente michel aún tradicionalmente
el bloque del 14 de marzo estaba
liderado por saad hariri y el movimiento
futuro pero ahora con la salida política
de hariri los parlamentarios suníes
tendrán que hacer nuevas alianzas y esto
sin duda traerá ventajas al partido con
más poder que en este caso es hezbollah
en alemania hubo también elecciones
regionales en el estado federado de
renania del norte-westfalia según los
últimos pronósticos de las 21 45 hora
local aportados por la televisión
pública alemana zdf
el partido conservador cdu habría
obtenido un 35,8 por ciento de los votos
para palo para el partido
socialdemócrata del canciller olaf
scholz que se dejaría 46 puntos
porcentuales y se quedaría con 26 por
126 6% de los sufragios los verdes
habrían subido a 11 puntos y medio y
alcanzaría en el 17,9 por ciento de los
votos estaremos atentos a los resultados
definitivos
y el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden hizo este domingo un llamamiento a
trabajar juntos para enfrentar el odio
tras el tiroteo en un supermercado de
búfalo en el estado de nueva york-
perpretado por un supremacista blanco
que dejó al menos 10 muertos y luego de
que la vicepresidenta kamala harris
afirmara que el país vive una epidemia
de odio el presidente informó asimismo
que la policía está investigando el
hecho como un crimen de odio motivado
por el supremacismo blanco
todavía estamos recopilando los hechos
pero ya el departamento de justicia ha
declarado públicamente que está
investigando el hecho como un crimen de
odio acto de supremacía blanca y
extremismo violento por motivos raciales
mientras lo hacen todos debemos trabajar
juntos para enfrentar el odio que sigue
siendo una mancha en el alma de eeuu los
corazones están afligidos una vez más
pero nuestra determinación nunca debe
flaquear
y en noticias de américa latina cuba
aprobó este domingo su nuevo código
penal en medio de críticas por parte de
los opositores y de activistas temen que
este nuevo código dificulte aún más la
protesta y el periodismo libre en el
aumentan los tipos delictivos en 37 y se
endurecen las penas con cuatro delitos
más que conllevan la pena de muerte que
en la práctica no se ha usado en cuba
desde hace casi veinte años para los
impulsores del cambio supone sin embargo
la modernización del anterior código de
1987 que no medía aspectos como la
violencia de género o los crímenes
ambientales
la norma jurídica se proponen tipifica
como delitos los hechos más graves y
lesivo para la sociedad y protege los
intereses generales del estado y el
pueblo y también los individuales de las
personas como garantía de la estabilidad
de la nación la seguridad jurídica y la
tranquilidad ciudadana y acabamos con
noticias deportivas y el primer título
del año para el tenista serbio novak
djokovic que se impuso en el abierto de
roma sobre el griega este faro sí sí
pasen una hora y treinta y ocho minutos
el serbio doblegó a su rival con un
primer set que acabó con 60 a favor de
djokovic el segundo lo ganó en el
tiebreak por 7 a 6 gran victoria antes
de roland garros el principal torneo de
tierra batida del circuito mundial de
tenis y donde justamente derrotó a chips
y pass el año pasado en la final
hasta aquí este repaso a la actualidad
internacional sigan conectados a france
24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]